rising trade fight between the US and
its economic allies led to big sellouts
on Wall Street the Dow Jones Industrials
NASDAQ and S&P 500 all dropped sharply
yesterday shares of harley-davidson fell
almost 6% the motorcycle maker based in
Wisconsin told the SEC that retaliatory
European Union tariffs will force it to
move some production out of the US more
than a year ago a Harley executive is
met President Trump at the White House
to celebrate the company's success
yesterday he claimed on Twitter
ultimately they will not pay tariffs
selling into the EU CBS News financial
contributor Mellody Hobson is with us
from Seattle good morning melody good
morning John so you talked to some folks
at Harley Davidson the president says
well this'll all get worked out what are
they feeling so I talked to someone very
close to the company and they made it
clear that this is a big problem the
company is very troubled by this and
they have to act because they have
40,000 bikes that they sell in the EU
it's their second biggest market it
represents 16 percent of their revenues
and they can't afford to lose the sales
so when tariffs go up by 25 percentage
points you have to do something because
they feel they cannot pass on what would
be on average about $2,200 per bike they
cannot pass that cost on to their
customer the melody have you heard how
many American workers will lose their
job that's one question and number two
do you know what how what other effects
could we see because of this what are
other first they're not saying what the
job issue is now there's some statements
that have been made that jobs will not
be lost in America but they are also
saying very clearly and my source again
close the company made it very clear to
me that they feel like they have to
hedge their bets in terms of production
outside of the US simply because of US
policy and not knowing how to deal with
that this is a company that prided
itself and it's made in America themes
and they're saying we're being driven
outside of the company creating more
jobs because we have to if we have to
deal with these kind of trade war and
tensions the other follow-on the fact
that the person mentioned to me was
one they have to invest incrementally in
some of these facilities outside of the
United States they have not said where
there are where they are and they also
said you have to look at what we will do
with research and development how that
might be affected by this where those
numbers may have to go down
lastly interesting they said the tax
benefit they got from the tax cut that
was so trumpeted over the last few
months is basically being wiped out by
the fact that they're gonna suck up this
cost and eat the cost of the the tariff
cost for the buyer in the EU for the
next nine to 18 months they're gonna eat
that cost until they can get those
production facilities up and running
elsewhere in the world
all right so nullifying the effect in a
food right is what you're saying
nullifying the effect interesting that's
right all right thank you very much
Mellody Hobson always good to see you
eight subjects you're welcome